the commander of the Navy's Special
Operations Forces is sounding the alarm
about a breakdown in discipline in the
elite Navy SEALs his call to action
follows a series of disturbing incidents
involving members of SEAL Teams David
Martin is at the Pentagon so David what
prompted this dramatic step good morning
the Navy's top SEAL commander says some
of his his units have failed to maintain
good order and discipline so the seals
who were once the most glorified unit in
the US military their commander now says
we have a problem we've got a sense of
urgency Rear Admiral Colin green the
head of Naval Special Warfare put those
words in boldface and underlined them in
a letter he sent to his commanders after
an entire platoon of 22 seals was pulled
out of Iraq they had been involved in a
drunken fourth of July party which
resulted in charges of sexual assault
and then refused to cooperate with
investigators code of silence yeah code
silence are you not part of the
Brotherhood if you speak out against you
know whatever retired Navy SEAL Erik
Deming is one of several former and
current members of this elite unit who
shared stories of corruption with CBS
News is this a few bad apples or is this
a new system going wrong it's a it used
to be just a few bad apples but they've
been able to rot a lot of the applecart
the Perdue sent home from Iraq was part
of the same SEAL team as Chief Edward
Gallagher who was accused of murdering a
teenage prisoner there in 2017 he was
acquitted of that charge but convicted
of posing with the prisoners body his
commanding officer was accused of
knowing about it and failing to report a
war crime and another member of the team
was under investigation for having
committed perjury during the trial
Deming says he's become disillusioned
with the seals I got two boys that are
old enough and I wouldn't even let me be
part of it really would not and it's not
just the seals who have a problem the
Chief of Naval Operations has decided
the prosecution of chief Gallagher was
so
badly mishandled that he's thrown out
the charges against Gallagher's
commander and he has ordered a review of
the Navy's entire legal staff Anthony
very disturbing David on Afghanistan the
Pentagon is preparing to withdraw troops
from the country what do we know about
that decision David the u.s. military is
willing to go from the current level of
14,000 troops down to about 8,500 as
part of the initial peace deal with the
Taliban but here's the important thing
to understand about the prospects for
peace the Taliban want all foreign
troops out and the US military is not
willing to do that and the reason is
that Isis is also in Afghanistan and the
Pentagon says it needs to keep troops
there in order to go after Isis which is
still actively plotting terrorist
attacks against the United States David
Norton at the Pentagon thanks